Вже понад рік, як Андрій повернувся
назад до Києва
Сотні кілометрів відділяють тепер
його від лінії фронту
однак війна не відпускає його
Думки знову і знову повертаються у його минуле,
на Донбас
Коли ти тягнеш пораненого по снігу
а кулі лягають в тебе під ногами
ти падаєш, вони в тебе над головою
ти тільки кілька метрів пройшов, знову впав
тому що знову йде щільний вогонь
Андрій провів три роки на фронті
Після Майдану він пішов добровольцем
на війну на Донбас
Спершу в праворадикальний добровольчий батальйон "Азов"
це був найшвидший шлях потрапити на війну,
каже він
Пізніше він став санітаром
Брутальні воєнні будні, постійний страх опинитися під ворожими обстрілами
втрата побратимів не дають йому
та тисячам інших, хто був на війні
повернутися до нормального життя
Просто все нормально, рівно все, добре
і тут - раз, і починається жар в голові
починають мліти руки, ноги
починається тахікардія, стрибає тиск
бувають панічні атаки
Лікарі говорять про посттравматичні розлади
Його тіло самовільно викидає адреналін
Це постійно переносить його назад,
ніби він знову на фронті
Життя ветерана непросте
Якоїсь особливої подяки він не чекає, каже Андрій
але навіть елементарно знайти роботу проблематично
Роботодавці ветеранам не дуже раді
надто великий страх, що вони можуть вдаватися до насилля
або поводитися неадекватно
Допомоги від держави Андрій досі не отримав
Ми запитали в міноборони України,
але тут проблеми не бачать
Військовослужбовці, які повертаються з району (бойових дій)
вони мають певні дезадаптаційні розлади
які проявляються в підвищеній агресії
стурбованості
відчуттям іноді депресії
Але все це легко нівелюється у перші три доби
повернення військовослужбовця
і перебування у мирній обстановці
Понад 600 випадків самогубств
серед солдатів на службі
Ці цифри воєнної прокуратури вже місяцями збурюють українське суспільство
Однак міноборони не хоче визнавати
такої статистики
На одну тисячу чоловік
ця норма не перевищує загальнодержавної статистики
І говорити про те
що військовослужбовці здійснюють...
якась критична ситуація щодо самогубств
це не зовсім вірно
Там, де уряд безпомічний,
мусить долучатися суспільство
Ми у Верховині, в українських Карпатах
Далеко від Києва і від міської метушні
Учасники бойових дій можуть знайти допомогу тут
За підтримки психологів та арт-терапевтів
Усе це фінансується
виключно на приватні пожертви
Андрій на 10 днів потрапив сюди
в оточення людей зі схожими проблемами
Не треба...
об'єкти якісь зображати, якісь квіточки, зайчики, сердечка
тільки колір!
До війни Віталіна Маслова була вчителькою
Після Майдану почала працювати з посттравматичними розладами постраждалих
згодом це переросло в постійну роботу
Як спонукати дорослих, тим паче колишніх солдатів до малювання?
Я не люблю малювати - я кажу: "Попробуй!"
І часто це буває несподівано для людини самої
що от, я можу зробити щось красиве
Якщо тут ми маємо таке довірливе середовище
ми оточені красою, ми в безпечному місці
тоді вже можна задаватися якимись там моральними питаннями
питаннями самовизначення і таке інше
Коли ти востаннє малював?
Та давненько, якщо чесно. Ну такого - то ніколи
Почуття задоволення
відчуття, що мені це вдалося
Поки що в мене просто класний настрій від цього
Похід горами веде до гірської хатини
яка колись має стати постійним центром
для реабілітації таких, як Андрій
У селі добре до цього ставляться
Люди, які тут живуть,
вони допомагають нашим бійцям відповісти на питання, за кого я воюю
А приїжджаючи сюди в гори, зустрічаючи людей, які їм дякують
це теж дуже важливий момент
Колоти дрова, збирати яблука
чи просто милуватися красою гір
Нині як виняток кожен сам може вирішувати
чим йому займатися
Наскільки такий настрій передається в повсякдення солдатів
відкрите питання
Однак уже через кілька днів Андрія не впізнати
Той досвід і багаж, змінивши трохи
скерувати його в іншому напрямку
допомагаючи таким людям, як я,
звикати до мирного життя
З власного досвіду знаю, що це непросто
Вже понад рік, як я звільнився
а ще досі не можу до кінця прийти до тями
А це нелегко
Для арт-терапії на курсах Віталіни
більше немає вільних місць
Бракує елементарно грошей